can you comment about the war in Ukraine
so for me it's a deeply personal thing
um but I think you're able to look at it
from a geopolitics perspective what is
the role of the United States in this
conflict before the conflict during the
conflict and right now in helping
achieve peace I think before the
conflict the big problem is that the
West took
almost the worst possible view which was
encourage Ukraine to keep trying to join
NATO and the EU but don't let them in
and so what that does is it achieves the
purpose of getting Russia really really
ticked off and feeling threatened but
also does not give any of the
protections of NATO or the EU to to
Ukraine I mean zelenski is on film when
he was a comedy actor making that exact
joke right as Merkel on the other line
and she's like oh welcome to the welcome
to Nato and he's like great she's like
wait is this Ukraine on the line and
oops but so you know that that sort of
policy is is sort of nonsensical if
you're gonna offer Alliance to somebody
offer Alliance to them and if you're
going to guarantee their security
guarantee their security and the West
failed signally to do that so that was
mistakes in the run-up to the war once
the War Began then the responsibility of
the less began and became to give
Ukraine as much material as is necessary
to repel The Invasion uh and the West
did really well with that I think we
were late on the ball in the United
States it seemed like Europe led the way
a little bit more in the United States
did there but in terms of effectuating
American interests in the in in the
region which being an American is what
I'm chiefly concerned about and the the
American interests were several fold one
is preserve borders two is degrade the
Russian aggressive military because
Russia's military has been aggressive uh
and they are geopolitical rival of the
United States three recalibrate the
European balance with China Europe was
was sort of balancing with Russia and
China and then because of the war they
sort of rebalanced away from China and
Russia which is a real geostrategic
opportunity for the United States
it seemed like most of those goals have
already been achieved at this point for
the United States and so then the
question becomes what's the off-ramp
here and what is the thing you're trying
to prevent so what's the best
opportunity what's the what's the best
case scenario what's the worst case
scenario and then what's realistic so
best case scenario is Ukraine forces
Russia entirely out of Ukraine including
lohanesque and Crimea right that's the
best case scenario virtually no one
thinks that's accomplishable including
the United States right the White House
has basically said as much it's
difficult to imagine particularly Crimea
the Russians being forced out of out of
Crimea the ukrainians have been
successful in pushing the Russians out
of certain parts of johansenesque but
the idea they're going to be able to
push the entire Russian army completely
back to the Russian borders that would
be at best a very very long and
difficult slog in the middle of a
collapsing Ukrainian economy which is a
point that zielinski has made it's like
it's not enough for you guys to give us
military aid we're in the middle of a
war we're gonna need economic aid as
well so it's a pretty open-ended and
strong commitment can take a small
attention on that and your best case
scenario if that does militarily happen
including Crimea
do you think there's a world in which
Vladimir Putin
would
um be able to convince the Russian
people that this is this was a good
conclusion to the war right so the
problem is that the best case scenario
might also be the worst case scenario
meaning that there are a couple of
scenarios that are sort of the worst
case scenario and this is sort of the
puzzlement of the situation one is that
Putin feels so boxed in so unable to go
back to his own people and say we just
wasted tens of thousands of lives here
for no reason that he Unleashed a
tactical a tactical nuclear weapon on
the battlefield nobody knows what
happens after that so we put NATO planes
in the air to take out Russian assets do
Russians start shooting down planes does
Russia then threaten to escalate even
further by attacking an actual NATO
civilian Center or or even a Ukrainian
civilian center with nuclear weapons
like where it goes from there nobody
knows because nuclear weapons haven't
been used since 1945. so that's you know
that is a worst case scenario it's an
unpredictable scenario that could
devolve into really really significant
problems the other worst case scenario
could be a best case scenario could be a
worse we just don't know is Putin Falls
what happens after that who takes over
for Putin is that person more moderate
than Putin is that personal liberalizer
it probably won't be novantly if he's
going to be
ousted or probably somebody who's a Top
member of Putin's brass right now and
has capacity to control the military
or it's possible that the entire regime
breaks down what you end up with is
Syria and Russia right where where you
just have an entirely out of control
region with no centralizing power which
is also a disaster area and so in the
nature of risk mitigation in in sort of
an attempt at risk mitigation what
actually should be happening right now
is some off-ramp has to be offered to
Putin the offer I'm likely is going to
be him maintaining Crimea and parts of
luhanskin denesque it's probably going
to be a commitment by Ukraine not to
join NATO formally but a guarantee by
the West to defend Ukraine in case of an
invasion of its borders Again by Russia
like an actual treaty obligation now
like the BS treaty obligation and when
Ukraine gave up its nuclear weapons in
the 90s
um and uh and that is likely how this is
going to have to go the problem is that
requires political courage not from not
from zlanski it requires courage from
from probably Biden because the only
zielinski's not in a political position
where he can go back to his own people
who have made unbelievable sacrifices on
behalf of their nation and freedom and
say to them guys now I'm calling it
quits we're going to have to give them a
handstand asking give Putin an off-ramp
I don't think that's an acceptable
answer to most ukrainians at this point
in time from the polling data and from
the available data we have on the ground
it's going to actually take Biden biting
the bulletin being the bad guy and
saying to zielinski listen
we've made a commitment of material Aid
We're offering you all these things
including essentially a defense pact
we're offering you all this stuff but if
you don't come to the table then we're
going to have to start weaning you like
there will have to be a stick there it
can just be a carrot and so that will
allow salonski if I'd want to do that
would allowski to blame Biden for the
solution everybody knows has to happen
so once you can go back to his own
people and he can say listen
this is the way it has to go like I
don't want it to go this way but it's
not my I'm signing other people's checks
right I mean like this is it's it's not
my money uh and Biden would take the hit
because he wouldn't then be able to
blame Ukraine for whatever happens next
which has been the easy Road off I think
for a lot of politicians in the west is
for them to just say well this is up to
the ukrainians to decide it's up to the
ukrainians to decide well is it totally
up to the ukrainians to decide because
it seems like the West is signing an
awful lot of checks and all of Europe is
going to freeze this winter
so this is the importance of great
leadership by the way that's why the
people we elect is very important
uh do you think
do you think there's power to just
one-on-one conversation or buying six
thousand skin Biden sits down with Putin
almost in person
because I or maybe I'm romanticizing the
notion but having done these podcasts in
person I think there's something
fundamentally different than
through a remote call and also like a
distant kind of uh recorded
political type speak versus like
man-to-man
so I'm deeply afraid that Putin outplays
people in the one-on-one scenarios
because he's done it to multiple
presidents already he gets in one-on-one
scenarios with bush with Obama with
Trump with with Biden and he seems to be
a very canny operator and a very sort of
hard-nosed operator in those situations
I think that if you were going to do
something like that like an actual
political face-to-face Summit what you
would need is for Biden to First have a
conversation with zielinski where
zelinski knows what's going on so he's
aware and then Biden walks in and he
says to Putin on camera here's the offer
let's get it together let's make peace
you get to you get to keep this stuff
and then let Putin respond have Putin is
going to respond
um but you know the the big problem for
Putin I think and the problem with
public facing fora maybe it's a private
meeting if the private meeting maybe
that's the best thing there's a
public-facing forum I think it's a
problem because Putin's afraid of being
humiliated at this point um if it's if
it's a private meeting then
sure except that again I just I wonder
whether
when it comes to and a person as canny
as Putin and to
a politician that I really don't think
is a particularly sophisticated player
in in Joe Biden and again this is not
unique to Biden I think that most of our
presidents for the for the last 30 40
years have not been particularly
sophisticated players uh I think that
that's that's a that's a risky scenario
yeah I still believe in the power of
that because otherwise
um
I don't know I don't I don't think stuff
on paper and political speak will solve
these kinds of problems because from the
zielinski's perspective nothing but
complete Victory will do right he is as
a nation has people sacrificed way too
much and they're all in and if you look
at as I travel to Ukraine I spent time
there I'll be going back there hopefully
also going back to Russia just speaking
to ukrainians
they're all in
they're all in yeah nothing but complete
Victory yep that's right and so for that
the only way to achieve peace is through
like honest human to human conversation
uh giving both people a way to off-ramp
to walk away Victorious and some of that
requires
speaking honestly as a human being but
also for America to the actually not
even America honestly just the president
be able to eat their own ego a bit and
be the punching bag a little just enough
for both presidents to be able to walk
away and say listen we got the American
president to come to us and uh I think
that makes the president look strong not
weak I mean I agree with you I think it
would also require some people on the
right people like me if it's Joe Biden
to say if Biden does that I see what
he's doing and it's the right move I
think one of the things that he's afraid
of to steal me on him I think one thing
he's afraid of is he goes and he makes
that sort of deal and the right says you
just cowered in front of Russia you just
you just gave away Ukraine whatever it
is
um but uh you know it's going to require
some some people on the right to say
that that move is the right move and
then he'll buy it if Biden actually
performs that move